hello everyone I haven't shown a holy
song game yet on my channel and I think
you'll really enjoy this one
holy fun was well for the most part of
her life considered to be a prodigy she
was the youngest player ever to play in
the fideo World Championship for women
when she was 12 years old she got her
women Grandmaster title when she was 13
and her international Grandmaster title
when she was 14 years old and she was
world champion three times and well ever
since her loud protest in Gibraltar last
year I don't think she'll be playing the
women only championships probably ever
again after she resigned that gaming's
in I believe it was five moves but this
game was played in 2014 in the women's
Grand Prix Championship organized by
fidei and the Holy Father with the white
pieces is playing against Nana's leg
needs also a very strong Grandmaster so
we have E for c5 Knight to f3 d6 the
Sicilian defence
d4c captures on d4 Knight captures on d4
MLA six the Khan variation and one other
thing about this game I really enjoyed
because Nana's didn't really do any
mistakes that could be considered to be
blunders but it's just that every move
Ethan made was was just a little bit
stronger and in the end it culminated
into into a beautiful attack so let's
continue the game
we have c4 de mer oxy bind Knight to f6
Knight to c3 and Queen to c7 and Bishop
to e2 now we have b6 even castles and
Bishop to b7 developing that light
square bishop and attacking d4 bond so
you can defense it Queen to d3 we have
Knight to c6 and okay black develops a
knight and well there are ideas of night
before and I to e5 which would kind of
hurry up the Queen on d3 so you son
decides to exchange the knight Knight
captures on c6 and D captures on c6
making room for that
rook to grab an open D file even plays
at f4 and we have a Bishop to c5 which
temple on the King being check so black
and castle safely we have Kim to H
one and now nana castles we have E 5 by
holy fun attacking that night and now
first rook a to d8 with a sample on the
Queen and you can place Queen to h3 so
the knight has to move since its attacks
in Knight to d7 and now we have a nice
de for and you see this is a very
interesting point even though this
Bishop was developed with Stamper with a
check on the King and the black king
went to safely to castle
now this Knight gets a temple on the
Bishop dispositioned very nicely on e4
because black definitely doesn't want to
exchange this bishop for a knight so
white wins the temple back we have a
Bishop to e7 and our Bishop to d3 and
already this position is the well it's
enjoyable for white there are some some
threats here on this h7 square for
example black would really enjoy playing
Knight to c5 here for example attacking
this Bishop and this strong night but
this losses immediately tonight's to f6
check and whatever black plays zero
capturing the knight or moving the King
it's let's say G captures on s6 simply
Queen to h7 checkmate so black has to
first protect against threats like this
and not applies g6 we have b3 probably
the only thing even has to do is if you
rather wait how to develop this dark
square Bishop we have c5 and our Bishop
to b2 and gnana captures Bishop captures
on e4 and it was a very important to
capture this night because if black were
to continues again with something like
b5 then nice step six check Bishop
captures on f6e captures on f6 and this
is a very unpleasant position for black
as the queen is ready to jump to h6 and
the black would have to further weaken
his position with h5 or something just
you know to play on so after Bishop to
b2 now decided to capture this knight on
e4 and okay I mean the bishop and b7 is
pretty strong but the knight on e4 is
also preparing to become really strong
so we have Bishop captures on e4 and now
Bishop captures on e4 and this is the
world kind of a critical moment in the
game the move black black has to play
here with f5
you know it's pretty hard to commit to a
move like this if you don't really see
why why you should play it so she
continued with b5 and this gives defund
the opportunity to execute a brilliant
attack
she plays f5 and okay what what's the
idea here of course she wants to bust
open the kingside and but this does seem
like it's losing the pawn and black
doesn't want to capture with G pawn you
know to open up a scheme so definitely
he will capture she will capture with
the e pawn but this allows rook captures
on f5 and the rook cannot be captured if
the rook is captured then Queens the f5
and there is no way to defend Queen
captures on h7 so non-authorized Queen
to b6 now defending this g7 pawn and
also protecting the 6th rank but even
place Queen to h6 and this is a this is
a very dangerous move for black as the
threat here is roof to h5 with William
unstoppable checkmate if the Rope is
captured in simply Queen captures on h7
because the bishop is now also attacking
it
so the rook must be captured we have G
captures on f5 and now not opened up the
attack on the Queen and h6 this was also
part of her plan by playing Queen to b6
but here a very nice continuation by how
you find out she plays e6 and the well
it doesn't matter that it detects denied
the real threat is Queen Queen to g7
checkmate as now this Bishop is this is
extremely strong on this diagonal so now
tries to defend with Knight to f6 and
now even plays Queen to g5 and in this
position
I'm not resigned because what's the
threat well it's actually an unstoppable
checkmate in five moves after Queen to
g5 and King to h8 you have Bishop
captures on f6 with check only move it
Bishop captures on s6 and now not
capturing the bishop with check but
Queen captures on f5 and there is no way
to defend Queen captures h7 checkmate so
yeah definitely a beautiful game but
bye-bye the three-time world champion
holy fun and like I said I really enjoy
it because
like I didn't actually make any mistakes
that could be considered blunders it was
just that
holy son plays the game well superbly so
yeah and I'm interested what do you
think since holy fun is one of the three
women that were ever in the in the top
100 chess players in the world what do
you think are her chances you know to
maybe break through into the top 20 in
the world or maybe even the top 10 so
yeah thank you all for watching as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and I'll see you soon